hello and welcome to sky news review of
the week with me jane secker and the odd
couple
of fleet street kevin mcguire associate
editor of the daily mirror and andrew
pierce consultant editor of the daily
mail or kevin
always likes to say that andrew is on
the right when it comes to politics and
that he's just right
you can pretty much guarantee that
whatever news story we discuss in the
next half hour
they won't agree before we get started
let's get a taste of what the week
was all about more than 280 workers died
at a mine in turkey
the disaster sparked violent protests
against the government and
its poor safety record the teenage
cancer campaigner stephen sutton died
after raising millions of pounds for
charity
in just a few weeks david cameron went
on a charm offensive in scotland while
the coalition went to war over free
schools and
free school dinners the education
secretary was accused of being a zealot
but michael gove says he's now made
peace with the lib dems
so you and nick like a pistol made up
have you
you could say that there were
celebrations as man city came out on top
again
the premier league boss richard
scudamore was under fire for sending
sexist emails
two regions in eastern ukraine declared
themselves independent in a vote
recognized by nobody
conchita wurst came home a heroine after
winning eurovision the cross-dressing
singer had faced opposition from russia
she had this message for president putin
i said it
clear we are unstoppable and a heroic
cat in california won our hearts after
saving its young owner
from a dog attack
oh eurovision is that time of year isn't
it what did you make of countries a
worthy winner what do you think of the
song
uh i can't remember the song but i
thought she was a worthy winner just for
being brave enough to wear a rock and
have a beard i'm saying she should i be
saying he
i don't know i wouldn't want to offend
anybody by by making
that call i love eurovision she she says
she
do do you think it showed us that we are
all a bit more open-minded
i think we are we got to celebrate that
we were laughing with not at
tackles prejudice if you can make an
enemy of some russian
uh you know really horrible people well
that's not uh bad in their leadership
and
i just wonder if we're gonna win in
britain maybe we'll just have to bring
out sandy shaw from retirement and stick
a beard on her or something because we
never we'll ever get into we saw loads
of different celebrities tweeting
pictures themselves with beards which
was very funny i thought
that's great well russell brand wasn't
it he was very clever about it nigella
lawson was one of the
one of the early winners but more
serious story this week a change of
government in india
yeah could it be the end of that gandhi
dynasty um and of course it looks like
bjp
big big majority new prime minister modi
now he's got a
reputation for sectarian politics hindu
nationalists in the past
links to the killings of
muslims in riots and there were travel
bans on him uh
in many parts of the world until
recently so is it good for india
this it was the scale of the election
which is awesome a population of 1.2
billion it's taken them
more than a week to count the votes
we're going to the polls in britain on
thursday european elections
half the population 500 million though
it feels to me like
most of them have moved to britain and
it's going to take us
four days to count the votes we're going
to be talking about immigration in a
little while so let's not get into it
too soon yeah
let's take a look in more detail at some
of the stories that you've picked out
for us these are
the stories we've picked out during the
week and we're starting with the
dreadful story
coming from turkey and this is the mine
disaster 282 miners it's now believed to
have died there's still possibly more
miners trapping up beneath the ground we
don't know whether they're alive or dead
but the most remarkable political aspect
to this is the complete incompetence
of the turkish prime minister who went
to the scene of the
mining disaster compared described it as
rather ordinary
then had the cheek to compare it to two
19th century mining disasters in britain
when of course the owners of the mines
didn't care a fig
about the welfare of their miners all
they cared about was profits
and then there's been been riots around
the prime minister's one of his aides
was
reportedly trying to kick protesters i
predict this
he'll be gone in days it does seem to be
spectacularly badly handled
on top of the fact that it is obviously
an enormous tragedy and desperate
for these families who still haven't got
answers yeah and yeah the prime
minister's behaving like an old ottoman
sultan who didn't care about these
people
uh and yes i think he'll get a reaction
but he's been on the side of private
business and
in a real rip-roaring turk success story
in one way if you look at economic
growth but it's often at the cost
of uh health and safety mine safety is
very poor it's been privatized it's
happening across the construction
industry and i hope you'll get an
electoral
backlash he deserves to get an electoral
backlash for this and
for once i i agree with him but people
died in mining disasters in
in britain so many numbers in the 19th
century because there was no health and
safety and lies were
considered cheap let's move to nigeria
now
another desperate story of the week this
is of course the ongoing search for
these
school girls nearly 300 school girls we
saw this footage
we don't know how these girls are now we
don't know what happened to the rest of
the girls do we yeah and the
the terrorist islamist terrorists that's
what they are in boko haram a really
backward theocratic
book parading the girls making them wear
their their head covers
making them convert to uh to islam and
they are the
kind of the the klu klux klan of the uh
the muslim world let's just take a look
at the video that has emerged this week
of the girls in a bit more detail
this will be tortuous viewing for the
parents of the missing students
young girls believed to be those
snatched in the middle of the night
paraded by boko haram as new converts to
islam
all those in the video were wearing
hijabs the muslim headdress
and chanting prayers in both the local
language hausa
and arabic they're in what looks like a
rural location and appear quite composed
given the circumstances
one of the girls stands up and looking
nervous recites a prayer
and the cameraman can be glimpsed with a
gun over his shoulder
the boko haram leader is not seen with
them but he taunts the authorities for
17 minutes about his captives
well that was our special correspondent
alex crawford who's been covering the
story from borno state in
nigeria and there are whole villages
aren't there that have lost
all of their daughters yeah and and the
conduct of these territories
absolutely sinister and again there's a
complete lack of
as a complete political failure just as
we saw in turkey
the president of uh of nigeria was due
to go and visit
uh the area where the girls have been
taken from and he's cancelled the visit
apparently he's got
more pressing business in paris where
presumably his wife can go shopping down
the champs-elysees
there has been this whole western uh
protest hashtag bring back her girls do
you think that's made any difference
i do i think it's it's made the nigerian
government sit up and take some action
and
i think it's deplorable that the that uh
good luck jonathan's not going through
the area
well there is an international summit in
in paris to try and get other country
and
britain us will be represented to try
and get a greater effort but no people
of the world
woke up the nigerian government so i
think i think that's
quite inspiring and i know you'll always
sort of look down your nose of people
who hold up
posters and so on but sometimes it
hasn't rescued them is it no but it's
the politicians keep saying
do everything we can and john kerry the
most powerful man on the planet after
the
president of the united states the
secretary said we're going to do
everything we can what have they done
nothing they've talked and mrs obama has
tweeted the odd picture
that's very racial you don't just don't
just dismiss it like that what ordinary
people
people do care of course they do but
they're not done anything to release
these girls they
may have to come to the conclusion
they're going to have to put military in
there
well look there are more people hunting
with surveillance planes drones people
on the ground now than they were before
and that is because people around the
world stood up and demanded action be
taken
let's move on to politics now an
exclusive poll for sky news has
suggested that ukip is on course for a
major victory in this month's european
elections our deputy political editor
joey jones has been taking a look at the
numbers
talkers of nigel farage's party at the
moment
and uh with good reason let's not forget
they're not even a fixture at
westminster but uh when you look at this
our euro polling
it tells a very good tale uh for ukip
there they are
up on 31 percent with the labour six
points back on 25
uh conservatives 23 and uh the lib dems
on a near
embarrassing nine percent there but of
course momentum
uh is always critical and there again it
points only one way a significant
steady rise for ukip since the beginning
of the year from the
mid to 20s up to that 31
the tories and the lib dems are actually
reasonably static which means that the
worries are really on the labor side you
have to look at this for a slide from
the beginning of the year
they were over 30 percent there and now
right down
uh to around 25 in this latest skypole
which suggests that the votes
are actually coming off labor and going
to uk which demonstrates that ukip are a
threat to labour and the tories alike
they're a threat to everybody aren't
they i mean do you think this could be
their best ever result
it looks like it of course farah just
said he thinks he'll top the pole if you
come second now it'll be it'll look like
a disappointment and you've got to go
back to 1984
30 years since uh an opposition party
didn't top the the poll i mean the main
opposition which
in this case would be labour if labour
don't do it it'll be a blow to red
miliband unquestionably
well he's had a terrible week because
the polls have been bleak and gloomy for
him
in one poll on europe not the sky one
actually labour in third place behind
the conservatives so that would be
catastrophe but general generally in the
polls twice now this week for the first
time
in two years the tories have gone ahead
of the uh labour party i don't know why
i'm a guy's laughing
and then and and the the real worry for
labor in his lot
is that cameron's lead over miliband and
personal approval ratings is widening
and on the economy there are 15.8
because it's not
i've got no idea boy you ignore all the
polls i put labour
first opponent you also the guardian
poll your favorite paper
you also ignore the fact that the two
polls you seize on would have still made
labour the biggest party in parliament i
mean
it's symbolism maguire the tories are
getting their nose ahead and as joey
jones paul showed there's no doubt
labour support is going down
because people have rumbled the two
edges let's get up to it next week i'm
going to bring a baylor here so you can
clutch
lots of straws because that's all you do
well all this talk brings us very nicely
uh onto our gaff
of the week and labour have not fared
well andrew
talks to what you picked well there you
are there's one of their posters
heaven knows how much they spent uh
getting the finest brains in the labour
party involved 450 pounds extra on your
shopping bill
and there's lots of food in the poster
there is no vat
on food and ed balls the shadow
chancellor took great delight
in saying that the post had gone
horribly wrong because he's at war
with uh douglas alexander who is
labour's election coordinator because he
thinks the entire strategy
is wrong you know embarrassing it is
it's silly error some of those things
are cleaning products and that yes
there's vat
but let's not miss the big picture which
is that a family is paying 1
350 pounds more in vit
as a result let's not miss that big but
what about the the other image the two
piece of the pod you don't think that's
quite a powerful image
well they're trying to say aren't they
that this is labor attacking the liberal
democrats the whole time in the european
election i think that's the wrong
wrong thing to attack they're all nine
percent they don't need to be attacked
anymore
and he's just trying to say that uh
clegg is cameron's
it's a bit like going back to the sdp
when uh the
spitting image had david steele in david
owens
top pocket that's what they're trying to
get i'm not sure it really works all
these cultural reference points are from
the 1980s
well we're staying with labour for the
other gap of the week and this is one
that you've chosen
uh kevin and this is uh austin mitchell
now he was talking about the proposed
takeover of astrazeneca by pfizer
uh and compared it to rape let's just
hear what he
said let's read his tweet cameron dare
not stop pfizer because he dare not
offend the us
in any way roll up rapists a few hours
later he said
naughty me substitute rapaciousness
before any more pfizer defenders weigh
in
silly mistake is a very decent guy
austin mitchell but you make a mistake
like that you
you know it's offensive language
apologize and then you move on but he
wouldn't apologize he dug in made a big
mistake he's retiring at the election
amazing though the labour sisterhood you
would imagine to pile in on this
uh if it had been a conservative mp
harriet armour would have been banging
the drums saying it's outrageous the
tourists shouldn't be
belittling rape nothing from labour's uh
shadow culture spokesman at all you know
why because it was an organized
move by the conservative party to make
it partly political and they got a whole
load of touring politics
yeah but come on he was asked to
apologize and he's refused this is what
this is what he said
no i won't apologize i wouldn't why
should i that's to give way to the other
side
if you want to apologize for everything
one said incorrectly i'd ask
all those conservative people be talking
about the rape of the countryside and
all those environmentalists have been
talking about the
rape of the rainforest to apologize too
so you can't apologize for everything it
may not be politically correct but it's
said now
i think you know the threat to
astrazeneca is still there
and we shouldn't ignore that by
concentrating on this
i have to say ed ball's the shadow
chancellor unlike kevin said he should
apologize look i said he should
apologize
no no don't misrepresent me mate i think
you should and
digging in just seeing it as trench
warfare where the other side is wrong
you know
you got it wrong just say it i'm sorry i
should have used a better term
we'll see right bit of a teaser for you
both now who was it
who said this it's awkward
is is what it is but um but i say that
and i still sort of have respect and i
want them to know that
the performance was done with
it's awkward is is what it is
but um but i say that and i still sort
of have
respect and i want them to know that the
performance was done with
with love it was done with love this is
the biopic it's right okay
apart from that that appalling
performance at the press conference we
should say that she's
she's responding to criticism because
because they said it's been it's very
wood and acted and it and it doesn't
have
facts well that's the thing what's
happened to her face that's the talking
point of monarch monaco not the terrible
film
but she's she's had it botoxed to death
hasn't she she cannot move anything
she's had more than maguire
more than you and i've got another he's
actually had
he had it under botox arms because they
were sweaty oh please
sorry too much information
let's move on now to the european court
of justice that this week is rule the
people have the right to be forgotten
you might want to forget that online
with huge implications for google
and other search engines well skies
technology correspondent tom cheshire
explains
16 years ago a spanish man went bankrupt
and put his house up for auction
when he googled his name that's the
information that came up first
he sued google because he argued that
information was no longer relevant but
was damaging his reputation
and now a european court has agreed and
it's ordered google to remove
any of that information from its indexes
this ruling has huge implications for
google
it is now saying the role that google
has in collating and displaying that
information when you put a search
request in is potentially unlawful
and that could be a threat to freedom of
speech jimmy wales the founder of
wikipedia
said on twitter when will a european
court demand that wikipedia
censor an article with truthful
information because an individual
doesn't like it
others will see it differently this is a
way of reclaiming at least
part of their digital existence for
themselves
wiping the slate clean so what do you
think i mean
you have there are some reservations
clearly but it can be something
i think it's the most appalling invasion
in encroaching on free speech ever
typical of the european union what's it
got to do with them anyway why are they
telling us what we can and can't do here
and you know in the three days
since that ruling 20 convicts have
applied to have their
records blanked out including one
involved in child
porn child pedophilia and a politician
who's seeking re-election
you know who this is going to benefit
people who've got something to hide
people who are victims of domestic
violence what about people who
that bad things have happened to them in
the past not their own fault and they
don't want to follow them for the rest
of their lives well i'm sorry it's
called free speech and you can't censor
it out you can't sense throughout
history
i always prefer free speech to to
censorship and on this i think it's a
perverse
ruling if something is true and it's out
there
in the open it's out there what you want
to cover it up where will you stop
because the people who will use it
aren't the people
you give an example of say somebody a
victim of domestic violence
it'll be crooks it'll be politicians
with shady pass
people you should know about the man
with the duck house will probably want
that exemple
kicked out of google the mp who came for
his duck house where will it stop
indeed right let's move on to the
newspaper stories of the week
um and there are lots and lots to get
through we're starting with
now this is desperately sad stephen
sutton of course we've spoken about him
before
and he finally lost his fight for life
this week without raising the most
extraordinary sum of money
yeah more than four million pound 19
uh he lived life to the full full of
zest and
i felt teary when i heard he that he
died because he was an inspirational
figure and he was a credit to to
humanity and it
shows you we often not young people and
they get make their headlines when
things go wrong
and of course they're involved in some
type of script but he was just a
positive figure and then i think we
we've all benefited from just knowing
about his story
and the tweet from his mother was
heartbreaking she said her heart was
bursting with pride
but it was breaking in half too because
having lost a son
far too young but but you think that
they must take some comfort from
what he's achieved and what an
extraordinary life he's had even though
it was very very strong and it's and
it's
it's reminded a lot of us because i
don't think i'd really work that one out
that how many young people
do die of leukemia and cancer no and all
that money these raised will help them
so i mean a fantastic legacy
right moving on to teachers andrew this
is a story that you picked out it's all
about what we call
teachers what people should be calling
their teachers one professor
says that she's concerned that miss is
is not on the same level as sir
ridiculous academic i mean we grew i
grew up calling my teacher miss
or as actually i was in a catholic
school sometimes i had to call her
sister so you can't you call nun sister
anymore if this professor has her way
because that's sexist it's ridiculous
you should call them this and call
themselves you're an old reactionary
let's hear from her she's called
professor
of language and linguistics at hampton
university jen coats and this is what
she says
sir suggests that the person being named
sir
deserves very high respect yes whereas
miss is a very
down-to-earth term it's just a term that
usually means a woman is
either young or unmarried
do you agree kevin yeah language matters
we've been discussing we've just
been discussing austin mitchell the
labour mp getting it wrong and condemned
him
sir gives you status a knight it was
what
kids used to call their fathers miss
goads back in schools to the time when
teachers female teachers weren't allowed
to be married
until 1944 don't know anything about
knights
this week saying as long as the kids
aren't saying or you yeah they actually
don't care what they're called as long
as it's polite
when i live in the east end of london i
remember talking to some children and
they talk
called their teacher by their first name
and i thought that was quite sad
actually because i think there should be
a distance between the teacher and the
child because the teacher's imposing the
discipline
and the authority in the far east it's
the teacher's surname and
teacher teacher brown teacher smith well
if you if you did that the same for men
and women
i'm great fine that's all right but at
the moment you've got a two-tier system
correct here we go little correct it's
actually about it's about respect
showing people respect it's absurd and
showing them equal
and if you did a poll on that i think
there'd be eighty percent
saying it's fine to call a mistake you
normally complain about polls
well we were talking about polls about
immigration earlier and we're back onto
immigration now this is the one that you
picked out kevin this is about the
number of
romanians and bulgarians that have come
to the country since all of the uh
plans were relaxed at the beginning of
the year that's right and despite all
those scarce stories about a flood 29
million
it dropped by four thousand you were
wrong wrong
wrong and you should just accept you
were wrong and apologize
actually can i just say i did not say 29
million would come in that was you you
were passed
but can i just point out to mcguire who
conveniently forgets
that this time compared to this time
last year there are 30
000 more romanians and bulgarians living
in britain because i think all the
publicity about them coming it meant
they came
anyway and there are 115
000 yeah more poles there are fewer i
admit
but there are hundreds can you just say
that there are you admit
there are 160 000 more eastern europeans
here
these rules have to be stopped it's
crazy we've got 2.2 million people
on the dole and it's falling quite fast
and about 2 million
over 2 million have flooded in since his
lot changed the rules
and didn't bring in transitional
arrangements it's a real problem
and it'll be a big issue in the european
elections on thursday and a big issue
at the general election which is why his
leader ed miliband has finally got
around saying they got it wrong
one of the reasons it'll be a big issue
is because you keep inflaming it
there are almost as many britons than
the rest of the european union as there
are other people from the european union
don't want a discussion about
immigration they don't want a discussion
about immigration because they know
they're
badly badly out of sync with the public
half an hour about immigration i know
you could well thanks very much for
taking us through your papers
very quickly what about your people of
the week we're starting with you andrew
and this is your first choice
good week for george osborne yeah great
economic statistics came out
employment is the highest it's been in
britain since records began in 1971 and
he's made
ed balls like a complete idiot again
tory boyd pixatory thank you there's a
surprise uh
bad week you've chosen again no
surprises
i promise you but his ratings ed
miliband's ratings continue to decline
they're sinking faster than ever
and the big american guru who's come
over david axelrod who was supposed to
be here to talk about strategy
is now here to try to show edmund how to
look ordinary on tv
too late on to your choices now kevin
and you picked
good week for rory stewart yeah those
who fear there's not enough aldetonians
in public life there we are
the tory mp is being elected chair of
the defense committee
he's actually knowledgeable on the
subject having worked in the foreign
office and once walked across
afghanistan and
lots of other countries so good for him
but bad week for
and perhaps no surprise tax dodger gary
ball take
that obe away and make him pay his tax
there he goes off he goes down to the
bottom of the list thanks very much well
thanks so much for
joining us for this week's review of the
week and don't forget you can catch
andrew and kevin in action on the sky
news press preview along with our other
pay-per-viewers as they take a first
look at the day's newspapers every
evening
at 10 30 and 11 30 on sky news and we'll
be back
with more next time from fleet street's
odd couple so for now it's goodbye from
them
bye-bye and goodbye from me bye-bye
you